- De lieutenant des vaccins
à cheffe des Forces armées
canadiennes. Anita Anand,
54 ans, prend la tête de
la Défense nationale.
Elle qui était jusqu'à présent
ministre des Services publics
et de l'Approvisionnement.
- Ainsi Dieu me soit en aide...
- Sa nomination arrive
à un moment délicat pour
l'armée canadienne, embourbée
dans plusieurs scandales
d'inconduite sexuelle impliquant
des haut-gradés. Sans commenter
ces allégations directement,
la nouvelle ministre s'est dite
prête à relever le défi.
ANITA ANAND, ministre
de la Défense nationale
- Je suis axée sur
les résultats. Donc, ce sont
des qualités que je vais
apporter à ce dossier.
- La tâche qui est en face
d'elle est équivalente
à monter le mont Everest.
- Mais la nomination d'une femme
à la Défense ne suffira pas
pour changer la culture au sein
de l'armée, croit cette experte.
CHARLOTTE DUVAL-LANTOINE, Inst.
canadien des Affaires mondiales
- Le travail qu'elle a devant
elle, c'est pas un travail
qu'elle peut faire en quelques
mois ou même en un an.
Ça va être des efforts continus
et répétés.
- Dans la circonscription
d'Anita Anand, en banlieue ouest
de Toronto, ses partisans
s'attendaient à une promotion.
- On frappe sur le bois...
- Le président de l'association
libérale du comté croit que
la ministre a brillé dans
son portfolio précédent,
où elle a conclu des ententes
pour obtenir plus de
400 millions de doses
de vaccins.
JEFFREY PERCIVAL, président,
Association libérale d'Oakville
- Elle était déjà chevronnée
dans le monde académique,
dans le monde juridique.
Elle a travaillé tellement fort
avec les vaccins, tout le monde
à travers le Canada a vu
son travail assidu.
- Plusieurs électeurs abondent
dans le même sens.
- J'espère le mieux pour elle.
- D'autres soulignent néanmoins
qu'Anita Anand n'a pas
d'expérience militaire,
contrairement à son
prédécesseur, Harjit Sajjan.
Au-delà de la question
de l'inconduite sexuelle
au sein de l'armée,
Anita Anand sera confrontée
à d'autres enjeux majeurs.
Cybersécurité, défense
de l'Arctique, conflits
asymétriques; autant de dossiers
qui pourraient compliquer le
mandat de la nouvelle patronne
des Forces armées canadiennes.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, Oakvill